[Music]
in stopping fake news Oh submitted by
Ashley oh how many Y's were that hello
that's a big Ashley YouTube will now be
linking Wikipedia articles to conspiracy
videos Oh what does that mean means
we're taking the fun out of it
but what if they link it to JK news with
the PD but yeah
so YouTube videos right yeah so here's
where it got just getting news because
we're going to talk about it it's
YouTube linking to Wikipedia Oh
silly way around yeah goddamnit YouTube
CEO recently Susan
why I don't know how to Susan why I hate
fun I can't watch me yeah
so she what a Chesky good she was
speaking at South by Southwest and she
was describing this new feature that it
will be linking YouTube conspiracy
videos to Wikipedia pages so they so the
viewer can find out information on their
own as to like the conspiracy video that
they're watching for example like the
whole conspiracy around the moon landing
in 1969 so videos about that like the
fact that NASA faked that the fact that
they faked it you said it's a fact and I
agreed with that no no okay
that's I said it wrong you know what I
meant you don't believe in the moon
landing that's not what I meant is this
you understand people are watching the
videos because I don't want to read
exactly that's the irony what are they
giving you a billhook it yeah so what in
the audience said so YouTube will be
sending people to text and then
everyone's are laughing but yeah so
she's like lon
no [ __ ] actually to clarify with some
Snickers from the audience not laugh
what's out not everyone in that crowd
ice straight-up
god just like that out of it that dude
right yeah and so this is all part of
like a broader discussion as to like why
what exactly social media platforms are
responsible for in terms of their
content nothing the idea that she has
though she gets her since she's the CEO
of YouTube to her when she sees the
YouTube and Lomb she sees integrity and
[ __ ] all this [ __ ] that doesn't
exist because we don't see it yeah we
just see like whatever the [ __ ] it's a
platform for cat video right and that's
it baby videos and all [ __ ] yep I
mislabeled videos that turn out to be
poor no worries we're just we're just
glorified cat videos that's it yeah but
that's one of them saying like we know
we understand what the brand really is
and she's like gosh I don't stand her
yeah and then she's new to I think she
came in the system 2014 I believe or
something like that
she's she's she rose to that position
dollars trying to she's trying to bend
the brand around something else yeah
that's the problem
comedy more advertisers yep course yeah
I mean that's what that's what that
means if you want to do that accommodate
advertisers [ __ ] I better see my CPM
to jump like a [ __ ] then yeah
I've been waiting for that for ad parody
yeah it's like dude radio stations
nobody listens [ __ ] anymore and they're
still killing it again thank you all
washing dollars right like why hasn't
that caught up yeah you know big boy on
now he's on 92.3 the beat or not to be
with the whole time enough 92.3 whatever
that's called as a Katy now when they
were when he was leaving power there was
like a bidding war going on and he was
getting paid two million dollars a year
plus plus a $70,000 vehicle allowance a
year and he's on the local level what I
mean like no one outside of LA is gonna
listen to him right and that's amount of
money
it's crazy yeah it's nuts and those
local stations like they don't even get
a hundred thousand listeners some like
during the day what screams Oh
considered local with iHeartRadio now
anyone can listen to any radio Radio is
going bankrupt yeah yeah [ __ ] ain't
working out but damn be purchased too
much huh yeah cuz I bought all the radio
stations up all the local stations yeah
so it's just kind of funny and ironic
the fact that they want like she just
feels so responsible to need to link
people to legit information
this is like pornhub putting like a
thing down at the bottom of every video
saying like you know masturbation can be
harmed but has harmful effects it's like
this is your business what are you
talking about conspiracy videos like the
biggest [ __ ] on YouTube now I love that
[ __ ] right is it still not super
reliable because they can be edited by
anyone I think people can actually quote
incite Wikipedia on their school papers
now oh yeah because it's like verified
now so is that you can't just be some
random [ __ ] putting up [ __ ] there
anymore yeah which is too bad because it
really harms trolling I think yeah I
think yeah thank you did you ever edit a
wiki page course really yeah all kind of
[ __ ] man I can't remember
I'll stop ahead I think I said no I did
some [ __ ] I can't even sense fun you
know I tried to write our own Jessica
new films a Wikipedia page like three or
four times and it gets taken out within
seconds yeah because you have such a
creative way of describing as you said
these guys rose from the ashes to be
[Laughter]
it's like obviously Bart wrote this you
gotta write it in a way that's just
objected to good-looking men the longest
longs ever to see the biggest fiercest
dicks I was like born from the center of
a lotus or like [ __ ] damn it he
didn't last more than it was like a
[ __ ] dandelion that grew out of the
concrete cracks or some [ __ ] he's almost
too good at sex Sergio Antoinette
I wasn't around at that time yeah but
she was just a girl Frenchy wasn't on
camera but the funny thing is the first
time we did it it didn't work out
utterly or do that no just kidding
he basically did it again with his
creative writing nice instead of just
writing facts I thought Phoenix's were
facts lotuses were facts I just gave up
after that I was like we're never gonna
happen
we probably still dummy doll no one ever
the trick was always to go to an obscure
celebrity's bio that nobody really looks
up very often and tweak that a little
bit that's [ __ ] up my go to Scott
Baio's looked up chachi
well we'll be back then no now he's
under fire dude sure what the boo you
don't say and you were a new right like
you know like while he was on chachi
like he [ __ ] a dolphin or something
like that yes three testicles exactly
you know it's funny though that's these
stuff I don't know where they get their
information from because one time I
googled myself and I saw this IMDB is a
DB or video I am I am Dewey I'm BD and
it said that I came out on Inside
Edition and all mine - no thanks I'll
keep it they fluff my [ __ ] up like crazy
yeah I'm a year younger those are a go
make sense your explains to be born out
yeah it's pretty close to Mexico
probably just mixing up all the people
I'm going to get into one who was born
in San Diego here I wasn't you were yeah
you were born in Korea yeah well who
knows this Wikipedia
Oh what the [ __ ] was his article about
you want the article about it's about
[ __ ] Susan woz news well what I
needed feature I will say what a
necessary needed feature you know like
who wants this nobody I feel like
YouTube just keeps [ __ ] up because I
didn't feel this way
when I first started YouTube and I think
for a good five years I
loved it like I had no problems I was
like yeah you're switching the algorithm
here and there but aside from that
whatever it's like a face facelift
whatever but now it's hurting now it's
like what the [ __ ] is happening will the
[ __ ] that they promote to make as the
face of YouTube is just embarrassing
yeah Barisan I really do enjoy
conspiracy theories because I like this
one guy he's like the ultimate flat
earther dude and he talks like this well
when you're a flat earther about that
fact I got that and they tossed about
dinosaurs never existed and excited this
guy is fascinating cuz he does this
thing where he like pulls facts but
he'll only use facts that goes for his
argument but but but people are in the I
love the comments because there's like
thank you for showing me the light my
new favorite youtuber this is guy named
BZ and so he lost like [ __ ] 30 grand
like on this thing called bit Connect
which is like a toy man right they could
a we went viral people know about it now
but it was like this whole scam everyone
even knew it was a scam Ponzi thing
where it's like you buy into big connect
you pay Bitcoin they give you bit
connect coins and you stake your tokens
and then you get a percentage of that
bitcoins and really what you're just
getting is new signups or they're paying
you for new shops right so a lot of
people would start YouTube channels and
then they would tell everyone like go
buy bit connect that's the [ __ ] I'm
richest [ __ ] I'm in the Lamborghini
Murcielago right now I got blown last
night by a supermodel and and then all
these like people would sign up and try
to participate in my connect so this guy
lost 30 G's in big connect which is sad
that's abundant and that's how I found
this guy he proceeded after that to
participate in this thing called Len
Connect which is another scam no any
part that he participate in this other
thing called like like fucking's connect
no it's sucking up it was called like
don't invest here err coin or something
like that or like fly coin and like the
the CEOs of that company just like
withdrew all the money and [ __ ] it up
Scott it and he had like 5 G's in there
I don't know well I don't know now I
know he works a grub up so he's he's
like
he keeps on swinging and missing so sad
it's so [ __ ] funny though cuz he's
like he's like steak it till you break
it so he just keeps saying that over and
over again he's like steak it do you
break it man stick it to you break it
and he's like lend it to you lose it and
then he's like I take the ELLs so that
you could take the dough because
everyone's making fun of him like hey
man you keep on buying all these scam
coins they're obvious game points that
we keep we keep telling you our scam
points and he keeps buying them dudes a
legend man you know what's so great
about this guy there's a fight
it's so entertaining be right and if she
doesn't even know it he doesn't know he
was amazing human beings yes they
provide like genuine entertainment
because they're not funny at all telling
you guys I think if he is he's a genius
and he pulled one over on me which is
which is awesome but he even like was at
a gas station and he swiped his card
somebody stole it
Nikki has been like like the past like
[ __ ] five nights Nikki's been like
what the [ __ ] are you laughing about
cuz I'm laughing so hard she hears me
laughing through the whole house and I'm
like crying cuz he's he thought Bob
these scams and everyone's warning him
and he won't take the advice guy is my
favorite busy check him out it's Billy
it's like one person scamming him just
constantly over and over I feast rollin
man he is the best I've ever seen
and why does what YouTube want to take
that away from us I know you're right
this is the only way I could see into
other people's lives and learn from it
well they're not necessarily taken away
they're just linking it to to text
[Music]